i met james armstrong when he was a
teenager he's since become financially
independent
he's now pretty wealthy he's got a very
nice portfolio
this is his fantastic place where he
lives
nice when i first met james he said to
me that he wanted to do property
development and he wanted to make
serious money and i remember saying to
james look you're gonna spend your first
12 months
packaging and selling deals for other
investors being a sponge
learning all you can learn and you're
gonna get there it's now two years later
let's see how he's getting on
here this is james armstrong
killing it in property when did we first
meet when you're how old i was 19 when
we're on the crash course
19 years old he came on the crash course
and he said he's going to do some great
things
you came on winners wednesday and that
video how many views has it had
60 thousand views mistakes for 60 60 000
views
and people are asking you a ton of
questions they're asking you questions
about
what your properties look like they're
asking you questions about are we
related
are we related we're not yet related he
is dating
my wife's sister so maybe well but you
did meet her after you did the crash
course
yeah so i'm on the crash course like the
12th of jan yeah day one two day course
i hadn't i met her before i all didn't
really know anything about your family
yeah so it was like two weeks after that
i'd already paid for the dfe at that
point
and so you pay for the training but
people people sometimes assume
that you got special treatment because
you were in the family but that's not
true right
no you you are the same on camera on
stage off camera at home
like you're the same anywhere you're not
like this different person who gives
special room to different people or
acts differently in front of different
people like and you dating
melissa you kind of even kept it under
the radar it's not like you did it to
try and get close to me or some messed
up reason like that so he is dating my
sister
uh in law he is killing it in property
is that if we have a little around
your little crib come on so what made
you want to live
in this place because it's absolutely
fantastic how did this how did that come
about
you know as a guy who finds houses for a
living you'd have thought it'd be easy
to find a place to live in
it wasn't it's really really difficult
we just wanted to be somewhere close to
like where my mate works
and then like pretty much anywhere i
want someone nice
so it was modern i did a bit secluded
and private like you know gates on the
rest of it
yeah and when i saw the castle that i'm
always living in and i met him
and started like looking around i really
really like this place you know
throughout all this lockdown there's
walks like there's loads of acres worth
of land you can walk down where they can
now i like
it and i actually think when you first
joined the academy
um i was just completing on the castle
when you just joined wasn't i
yeah i think when i started the academy
you didn't
yet own it you were like in the process
of buying it you bought it a couple of
weeks after that like that's one on one
or something what you've achieved in the
last
two and a half years though is is mega
you're making pretty good money in
property yeah what kind of is an average
month for you to make in property
just deal sources probably like 30 40
grand a month somewhere in that region
um crazy the last three backwards have
been around about 90 grand
so that that's how i can track it so for
the last nine months it's at least 30
grand a month
30 grand a month i've created a monster
i need to start asking your advice on
stuff i mean what
that's deal sources but what you've done
though is you've used that money
to start building your own portfolio
we're going to go inside one of james's
houses you don't own this place
all right in fact that that's one of the
things though
rent stuff that you use yourself right
you
you if you see him driving fancy cars
which you will see all the time
he didn't own it okay he doesn't own it
is that right 100 true he's gonna own it
this place right now that we're in nice
beautiful place do you own this
he didn't own it why because he's smart
that's that's being financially literate
why do you rent stuff that you have
yourself and then
buy stuff that you rent out what what's
the philosophy around that
this isn't an asset this doesn't pay me
like
i i have to pay bills here i have to pay
for the rent you got to pay for
everything else
when you buy a house and then you rent
it out it pays you every month yeah
zacky says on assets from the pays of
every month
yeah you know a car is never going to
pay you every month it depreciates in
value for starters it doesn't have it's
not a real asset
yeah and then if i buy my own place
let's say i take 200 grand or 100
50 grand i put a deposit in my own house
and all right i've got a house
i'll pay a mortgage rather than the rent
but if i took that money
and invested it in a house and then got
the rental income
the profit i'd make for that would be
bigger than the savings i'd make
on having a mortgage versus renting
money place correct so it's just a
commercial decision right yeah and i can
move out what i want
yeah i don't have to worry about what
the market's at when i want to sell my
house this is about
lifestyle so we're gonna drive down now
to your your patch which is north west
england we drive down to this patch i
want to see i want to meet melissa
because you guys are kind of doing this
together i want to see some of the
properties that you've sold to investors
i want to see the little house that you
just bought nice
all in our basta martins are james bond
drives master martin so i like it
hey you look so low down hi there
yeah whoa um i was using that to support
to hold on to it he just disappeared
so i assume i'm gonna follow you up yeah
all right cool
i'll see you in about 10 minutes if you
can keep her oh if i can keep up
all right
and yours is already on to left yeah
nice one i like it
yes it so it looked exactly like this
one horrible
yeah um the back the the guttering
looked pretty much the same as that one
at the front so
yeah you know what it's amazing how much
difference
painting a house now so i bet this car i
bet that cost you
300 quid not even though how much was it
uh i actually did a deal with a builder
and got it in for free but it would have
been about 150 quid okay
so for like 150 quid the difference
between this house and this house
if you were coming around to view it to
let it if you're a valuer coming around
you just straight away gonna think this
is nice we always say this like when
if you're gonna have a house revalued
it's gotta look good when they
see it the first thing they see is gonna
look the house and if it looks a bit you
know tired and worn yeah then it doesn't
matter how nice it is inside it's like
first impressions i'm sure when you guys
first met
all right all right show me this around
in fact because i haven't seen it
yes it is hi
how are you doing
good stuff hi so again when i bought
this this was like some old
like horrible archway here yeah i had
like duck a little bit to get through
but
the stairs are if we can't really go
actually higher but it's made a big
difference just squaring it out it's
getting a bit more space what do you
think
i love it it's birthday if ever things
don't work out
for you guys financially just come and
sit up here yeah just come and set up
your phone shop we've got a nice little
you know lounge area
mixed in with a bit of a dining area
there and then we had big
like brickwork sort of like mantelpiece
fireplace type thing like all the way
through into the next room so this looks
like
almost finished now works wise yeah i
mean
you got what like a week left or less um
i mean pretty much the weekend we lost
the lads while they're here and ask them
yeah
when are you planning on finishing
[Applause]
pretty much today
fair enough no that's it tomorrow to
finish all the rest of the decorating
so there you go it's done this weekend
yeah there's just a few sockets and what
not to change
coming in on sunday to do that and then
yeah
yeah it makes a big difference
yeah daniel daniel gave me a ring this
morning to let me know but
we're we'll get it fixed having a new
fan
oh this is nice yes this is a new
kitchen
this is a new kitchen so yeah the
biggest thing left to do now is just
clean everything
it's being revived on monday so it'll be
done this weekend
wow nice so you've got a busy weekend i
mean i don't yeah
yeah but yeah and then out here we've
got a little sort of like
utility space type thing for a fridge or
whatever and then a bathroom which to be
fair
the bathroom was in decent nick when we
got it it was just kind of poorly fitted
so the grouting was poor the silicone
was poor
you know there was some horrible like
upvc around here and stuff so we've
basically just
tied it up and fixed some of the shoddy
workmanship it reminds me very much of
my first house in maryvale road
yeah it's it's very very similar and
just the feel to it as well it's got a
good feel
good feel we should definitely go out
the back because we've done some done
some work out there
um this house came with a lot of damp
there were chimney problems there was
guttering problems the sucking felt was
missing at the back
and um this is one of those weird houses
where it doesn't actually have gutters
so the way it works you can see the new
lead flashing at the top there
um the the roof sort of finishes and
then the top of it there's some
basically some concrete pieces that are
kind of like a u-shape and then you line
them with lead so there's just a solid
gutter that runs the whole way down the
street
um and it was yeah the lead was gone
like it was horrible there was so much
damp in that top bedroom
so presumably this is just rendered in
its brick construction right
correct yeah yeah yeah but the render
was in really poor condition as well so
we just kind of
patched it up a bit and then painted it
it didn't really need a lot doing to it
um but yeah the house is looking a
thousand times better than i was first
here and location wise
good location this is a really good run
feels nice feels nice
you can literally see the church and it
feels very villagey
yeah and then you're on the street
there's not like rubbish bags outside
you know it's not like
there's no broken windows or anything
like it's a decent area so
how much did you buy this house for
forty eight thousand
forty eight thousand pounds not bad and
you've spent how much on it
thirteen thousand two hundred including
the vat okay
you paid stamp duty presumably yeah
three percent of
48k so a bit less than 1500 quid yeah
okay so all in what was your total
investment to buy this place
uh it was 64 000 pretty much on the dot
yeah pretty much like within 50 quid it
was and some people might be wondering
how did you afford to put 64 000 pounds
cash into this project did you use your
own money no
what how did you finance it i raised
some finance from an investor so they
had
a reasonable amount of money they're in
a little bit of a difficult position
because they can't get mortgages because
they've got a complicated financial
history of something along those lines
i said okay why don't you give the money
to me i'll give you a fixed return
because they were planning on buying
everything cash and making like six to
eight percent i said i'll give you more
than that just give me the money
yeah so over seven years i've got 130
000
at fourteen percent which is a bit more
than i wanted to pay why did you borrow
a hundred and thirty thousand
because i'm doing another house and so
okay so so so you're paying
how much ten percent fourteen fourteen
which is a lot which is a lot but 130k i
can do a lot with it
yes you know so i for example there's
this one going on there's a flip in
south wales i'm due to complete on
pretty soon
um i haven't even seen that one once
actually as it happens
um and how when did you last see this
house
february so that's months and months
how can and you've never seen that never
seen it yet
like it's going ahead and everything's
going well like power team man
yeah power talk to me about that so the
builders aren't doing this they're
actually
contractors they're house builders they
don't do small refurbs but because we're
doing something else with them which
we're seeing later
um i basically was able to pull their
leg and get them to do this for me and
they've done it at cost
which is obviously really really good
but we're planning on doing joint
ventures with them so it's on the back
of future business coming down the line
and just building up great relationships
with people
and how and how do you how do you find
great relationships like that that's
networking around the same way you find
investors where do these where do these
guys come from
um these are friends of our architects
yeah from david from david
ah small world small world there you go
so yeah we're just just networking with
people you know asking for
recommendations half the time
we want to find builders in area that we
are new to i just
go on facebook groups go hey what
builders can you recommend there's
thousands of property investors out
there who have done conversions before
whether it be hmos or just you know
barry february finance
just ask questions i just get out in the
world ask questions
i love that all right show us more so
yeah that's let's let's go upstairs this
battle will be cleaned up but it's
probably going to stay as
is the boiler you mentioned i came up
with the warning light this morning so
the fan needs replacing which will cost
175 quid
so i'm going to do that and i could
replace the whole thing but i can take
out boiler insurance
which is like a 10 15 20 quid a month
and if it breaks and clear out the
insurance
right so yeah that's that's the plan
well it's better than having to suddenly
shell out a load of money
yeah exactly to replace it all together
and i wouldn't mind replacing it you
know because
i've got you know five ten years worth
of use but at the same time like i don't
need to spend the money i'm not going to
yeah so yeah carpets coming in over the
weekend but you put the carpet in last
because obviously you don't get paint
stains on it or anything like that
but you can already feel even with the
underlay it still feels fairly soft
yeah so when you're when you're looking
to do your refurbs get a cheap carpet
but go for
good quality underlay because then when
you're walking on it it feels like
you're walking on the cloud
it's really really nice why would you
recommend getting a cheap carpet that
lasts longer
a cheaper carpet lasts longer if you get
the hardware and stuff which doesn't
look quite as nice
yeah it's actually cheaper than some of
the really like expensive shag piles and
there are you know like
high-end sort of stuff yeah um and
ultimately you're probably gonna replace
the carpet next time television anyway
yeah you know coffee doesn't last
forever it's nice
yeah i like it i really like it
and like you said it is so soft to walk
on honestly
i'm hearing that from melissa as well
you want not just to pretty face right
now what do you do for a living i'm a
quantity surveyor
so you're in construction function
construction yeah full time so i i know
what to look out for
and this is really really good and
you've also not only are you full time
in construction but you've also done
our training yeah exactly i've done
property investment training by yourself
and
doing a lot of deals yeah a lot of deals
so i know what a good deal is and what
it what it looks like and obviously
you've done such a good job in tea
talking about the figures downstairs
you like that yeah haven't spent a lot
on what is pretty much a mid-house well
yeah that's the thing and the refurb
like
13.5 grand like that's quite impressive
and you even got a new kitchen and stuff
yeah so good well
this is the thing like even if i didn't
refinance it i just bought it cash at 64
grand
and i rented it out 4.75 by the way this
will probably get 500.
hey that's still better than you get in
the bank yeah you get from pretty much
any savings account any like investment
yeah well the the yield is quite good
the yield even if i bought it cash at
64.
like it's still it's still a great deal
even without refinancing it but that's
when we get creative
yeah which we're going to get to in a
few minutes so this room is the
interesting one
so literally all of this and you can
still see
like it's still drying out a little bit
up there and then
all of this wall all of this wall um has
all been freshly plastered the
architrave's still off
um because we're waiting for the wall to
dry out but you can still see a little
bit up there
massive chimney problems and like i say
with the guttering down there
like this walls are soaking wet it took
two weeks to dry out
just literally is the decorative gonna
sort this out this weekend yeah yeah
what's he gonna do to sort this out here
so it's actually dry now this is just
obviously the underlying plaster so
there'll be a little bit of touch at
work and then there's a fresh piece of
architrave to go on which is you can
hear the work going on downstairs
they're busy the valuation's coming on
monday so they're going to get this
finished
and the views are fantastic i'll
borrow the dirty window by the day which
will be cleaned obviously
really nice i find every time i do a
project
whether it be big or whether it be small
there's always things that i learn
through the process
now i know you've been pretty hands off
and the team have been dealing with it
what's been the learning points of this
project
you know the best thing i've learned
about this house is
is how the guttering works in little
places like this every little area has
little
like quirks about how they build houses
yeah and around here it's the way the
guttering works
and you can see obviously it's caused
issues as any guttering would but it's a
lot cheaper to fix
it's only 150 quid for the flashing as
opposed to maybe five six hundred quid
for
full upvc gutters and like downpipes on
the rest of it so
yeah that is something i did not know
anything about before do you plan on
building a portfolio in eckerington
or because i know some of the other
projects aren't they're close by but
they're not in akron itself
or are you going to let this one do i'm
going to build a portfolio of good deals
i don't really care where they are if
i'm honest with you if i have to go
somewhere and i've got to get actively
involved with stuff
then either my power team is not good
enough or that something about the deal
hasn't been set up right so it's not
passive
i don't want to be this guy who's like
super hands-on doing this doing that
like of course you can cause you
problems if you don't have the right
people in place
yeah which is why i won't do that so in
terms of where would i want my houses
hey wherever the money's good i
personally love this area
have you done an idea and you've been in
a lot of packaging selling have you done
much in this area
so funnily enough i was here about two
weeks ago i think
but you didn't even come to the house i
think it was the house oh my goodness
well i came on my own
you know james wasn't here but i
basically came with the intention of
trying to find
a barrier for every finance and i looked
pretty much
in this area and i have to say this
house is gold dust i feel like you did a
really good job finding it
because i had a look at houses nearby
and i couldn't find anything that
would actually stack up as well as this
one has so
i'm still on the hunt but i i will catch
up
so talking about this deal being so
great and the thing we've not gone to
is you've said that you bought it you've
said the price you paid for it the
amount that you put down in total it was
total of 64 grand including everything
what is the new valuation that's what we
need to know
i think we'll get the birmingham will
get 85 grand so obviously when you put
your application through for the
refinance
you can effectively choose your figure
within reason and then they come back
and say yes or no we're going to put
this through around about 90.
yeah i think we'll get 85 all day long
and that's why i initially expected and
i still think we'll get it
if if you look at 85k and you take 75
percent of that that you get from the
bank i only get 63
750 quid so this house cost me 250 good
that's insane incredible and that's what
i was looking for
and i'm still on the hunt for it so i'll
be honest
it is a lot harder now like this house
in the condition it was
probably now would go for 55 60. you
know there's a lot of people buying
way above and beyond what it is worth
for for houses in poor condition
but it's very difficult sometimes to
tell if between a 12 grand refurb like
this one
and say 25 grand refurb they can look
almost the same and you can have the
same level of damp but this whole room
was damp it looked horrible
but it didn't cost much to fix if you
were downstairs it was in the kitchen
and stuff we're going to put new dpcs
down there's five grand just some damn
courts in there
so you've got to be careful about when
you're looking at your houses and i
think if you're going to do brrs
and you want to get a good deal don't
overpay for your house and make sure
your refund figures are solid
you know because they can be money pits
i love that wood smell
fresh smell of pine man it's great it's
good i'm sure when you first bought the
house it smelled very different now it's
that good smell yeah
different different is the word it's the
finished
it's the finished smell
hey good to meet you guys yeah thanks
guys see ya
oh i absolutely love it so so good
honestly there are so many different
strategies out there like in terms of
what you can do in property you've got
lease options you've got single let's
hmos
and biowu february finance has just got
to be one of my
favorite favorite deal strategies i
think
obviously deal sourcing is fantastic and
i was super confused about
what a biofurby finance was and also
what the rest of it was but after the
training that obviously i went on in the
crash course and the dfe
i learned so much about how you can
actually do these deals
and when i started looking for my own
barry february finance deal
that's when i really got to the like
nooks and crannies about what it was
and this deal honestly the reason why i
kept on saying it was such a good deal
in there was because
you've basically been able to get this
money
from an investor you've been able to get
this house and drive the value
up and from that the bank will obviously
give you the money for when you
refinance and then you can pay back the
investor and you're just left with this
house
which is basically free it's incredible
you're like almost inspired
by james on james's behalf yeah but
that's and that's so cool that's why
we're documenting this because
you're inspired by seeing james's house
it's crazy you've never seen it
but i want loads of people to see this
and to see it work because i think that
and you know what your journey james and
both your journeys but
the way that you this house and the
other projects you're doing it reminds
me of my journey the only difference is
i didn't know about deal sourcing until
years later
that's why you did so well because you'd
already done the deals you've built up
that education base you've built
the understanding and the knowledge
about how all the strategies go together
so when you come to sell deals and
you're speaking to investors they're
like they have the confidence you know
what you're doing
not just because you've got proof but
also because you actually know what
you're talking about that's the thing
with what you're doing you're a deal
sourcer but the reason you're such a
successful deal sourcer
is because you're doing deals yourself
yeah and because i invested in my
education
like i took the time out you know when i
started out i spent three months solid
and i would say at least four out of
seven days in a week i was in a training
room with you
and other people and your trainers and
the rest of people in the academy just
soaking up knowledge for three months
straight before i even really started
doing anything yeah you know i was just
getting the information together so i
know when i'm on the phone to an
investor now and we're going through an
hmo deal
i'm not the kind of guy who's just left
out the utility bills because i forgot
to add it in kind of thing
yes you know and when you when you sell
the deals to people and they say how
you know how have you quoted your refurb
like i say would it cost this to do this
it costs this to do this yes
because i've done it yeah and because i
can prove it and because i learned it
when i was on on the academy
we went through binary february finance
and all the training that you guys have
paid for with me
yeah did you claim that back all of it
yeah of course you did
hi hi sarah so what's the setup here so
james
packages and sells deals to his
investors in this area
and then you manage them yes and how's
that going really really well
really well um we've got 200 rooms
currently six available uh two of them
doubles so
potentially eight people working house
so out of 206 that's high
that's good occupancy 200 rooms six
available
okay so you're happy for more hmo
investors to come into this area you're
like
yeah i've been calling round i've been
calling james i've been speaking to
people who we know
trying to get more people to buy here
yeah to create more rooms and i know
we've done a bit of business
in the past i think as well i know i
think um we've met before anyway
yes yeah i've been in the area should i
buy a hmong burnley yeah absolutely
you reckon so what's your background uh
construction
um so my dad was a builder i've grown up
on building sites
i went into the trades painting and
decorating and tiling
um from that the business grew but then
my dad sadly passed away and he was the
one who built the houses you know he was
a storm mason bricklayer
i didn't want to go down that route so i
went into management instead
um so we we do refurbs now i have a team
of about
about 20 guys who work for me on and off
like subcontractors
the things within property is there's a
big enough pie
for there to be multiple people making
money so the deal sourcer can make money
and then the manager can make money the
investor is obviously going to make
money that's the thing i like about
property the fact that everybody can be
happy
as long as people don't get too greedy
there's enough money in the pie what do
you think about that tina
yeah absolutely definitely and
definitely there's money
to be made in burnley i think we we
achieved on comrod
a higher return than what we thought we
were going to in the beginning
the gross friend's like 50 higher than
what we thought it was going to be what
do you think though about people that
say
burnley's oversaturated with hmos like
you're a manager
running specializing in hmos in burnley
what do you think about that if you've
got hmos in burnley i am desperate for
them at the minute
if you're struggling with your manager
or you're struggling finding tenants
am absolutely desperate i've got 600
people to house
before christmas and i have no rooms
none
so it's not saturated with hmos no
you know who you know people that say
that they're either they're either
financially [ __ ]
or dave from the pub told them that but
we're here with
in the horse's mouth here right now
giving true facts
how do you like the car it's very nice
it's very nice
you know what the best bit about it is
not speed or anything else it's just
that noise man
just that that rorty v8
should definitely get one of these want
to
buy
one the thing is i wouldn't buy one
because it
it wouldn't hold its value and for the i
could buy all these i could buy a house
and
i can't i can't justify it financially
it's just not the right thing to do
top tip there especially if you've got a
lot of houses get key safes
you never have to worry about keys again
we've got the keys for this one
this is not owned by james this is one
that you packaged and sold on right
yep the investor's happy very happy i
don't blame the investor because it's
completely full
so yeah this this house has been fully
refurbished like pretty much back to
brick
so yeah it's really really nice we won't
be able to go in the rooms obviously
because it's tenanted
yeah um but we've got one room here
we've got one room above it
another room there and then one room on
the top floor on the left so it's a
three-story house
it's in pretty good condition
are you happy good stuff man sorry so we
were the agent
we're with the agent yeah yeah who would
the agent but don't worry you can relax
relax man we're not here tonight don't
worry
it's kind of a tiny bit awkward coming
into this house because it's
full there's seven tenants in we can't
go in any of the rooms
i don't actually know why we're here i
just wanted to tangibly see some of
james's investors houses
it's good to see that they're fuller
this is on the narrow side right
it is but we've obviously for hmo
regulations all of this has been
fireboarded
so this is why the ceiling's been
dropped because it's been fireboarded
and this is why it looks the way it does
you've got the interlink smoke alarms
the fire doors all that sort of stuff
yeah we're really kind of 50 50 on
whether or not we replace the kitchen
and we were chatting with tina and she
was like look
hmo's hmos so they get a lot of wear and
tear you're better off replacing the
kitchen now
rather than say 12 months time to get
the tenants out and then replacing it so
you know what we
thought may as well we'll do it so the
investors bought this house cash
and they are planning on refinancing it
and to the start we weren't sure if we
were going to buy a cash or mortgage or
anything so actually it's turned out
really really well
putting a new kitchen in because it's
going to drive that value up even more
where did you find the property investor
for this house
um would you believe it they were a
contact that came in
they got in touch with me after my first
winners on a wednesday that i did with
you
there we have it so you came on winners
i didn't know that you never told me
that before so you came on when it was
wednesday
you came on winners wednesday did you
get a lot of people reaching out to you
after winners i did actually it was so
nice because a lot of people were saying
how much i'd inspired them to just get
started because obviously the 22 year
old uni student with a job like
i had lots of excuses to not get started
but lots of people were like
actually i can do it which is fantastic
how much money
do you think you've made james as a
direct result of being
on winners on a wednesday i'd say at
least 50 grand
like seriously if you go yeah i said at
least 50 grand i probably sold
i can i can count on my hands from
memory at least 10 people have bought a
deal from me just from winners on a
wednesday incredible
so yeah melissa deal sourcing
i know you've done deal packaging in the
past is that something that you're
actively wanting to do now what's the
next steps for you in your in your
journey and do you and james
are you kind of like together are you
separate like what's the crack
so at the minute obviously deal sourcing
was a fantastic way for me to raise a
bit of capital in the beginning of the
year
but now myself and james are going to be
doing a flip together
okay so that's kind of my my strategy at
the minute and that's what i'm
more so focused on so i'm looking for a
barbie verb
kind of and how are you going to finance
this so james is going to finance it
all right oh yeah when you said are we
together or separate yes so where
basically he's going to finance it i'm
going to find it and basically get it
all done get the referred
so you're going to do the work he's
going to put money in and where's the
money come from initially though where
did james get the money from your deal
sauce in business right
literally yeah profits from the deal
sourcing business yeah you know that's
the thing you need to be doing
making money here yeah deal packaging
rent to rents
whatever it might be make money and then
invest money
make money invest money make that's what
gets people wealthy yeah
exactly and delay the gratification now
when you start deal sourcing and you
start seeing that money come in because
believe me it doesn't take
that long before you can answer like
pretty crazy cash like
10 grand a month for most people is
seriously unobtainable and it's not that
difficult to do in deal sources maybe
three deals a month yeah that's less
than one a week and that's a lot of
money coming in you'll be really tempted
you know buy a nice car
go out have nice food and you know what
you can still enjoy a good life
and aston martin focus on investing
first the same way you know you're sort
of thinking oh i'm gonna put some money
now
put some aside invest it so i can i can
wait until later when i've got kind of
the money coming in to pay for that
do the same with your time you know
where the start you've got loads of time
invest your time now and if you're busy
you've got kids and stuff invest the
time now
so in 10 20 years time you can take all
the time out that you want and you can
go on holiday for six months with your
family i've got a full-time job and i'm
doing this on the side as well so you
don't need to just do property part-time
sorry full-time to get the maximum
benefit you can literally do it
alongside your actual
job and still make a good decent amount
of money every month if you want to it's
fantastic
and all i want to say to people is look
it's so
possible like you don't have to be a
genius you don't have to be minted when
you start like
you don't need anything really other
than the drive and the right attitude to
make it happen and that is it
get the education immerse yourself with
people in property
and just go heads in dive into it i
couldn't have said it better myself
so guys if you want to get into property
you want to become a property investor
developer
deal sourcer find deals push the value
up refinance it then the thing you need
to do
is firstly you need to subscribe to my
youtube channel you can do that right
here
also if you want to see james's winners
on a wednesday interview you can do that
right here
and if you want to see melissa's winners
wednesday interview you can do that
right here but of course don't forget to
subscribe and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you